and i got me a smoothie and oh i took
that first sip and
it's one of the healthy ones man and it
uh
got it just i wanted it i want
it it's a little too healthy you know
it kind of tastes like i'm just like i
stuck a thing into a plant
and i'm just sucking that big
[Music]
like i'm just just giving it
just really just giving that freaking
that little baby hummer to uh
to a plant you know like i'm just damn
taking down a damn
uh begonia or something face fur you
know i'm just
doing oil on the begonia this thing's
just heavy
i mean it may have dirt in it i have
that's the thing you go to some of the
smoother reason it's too healthy
it's too it's just like come on they
just go too far with it
you know it's just too much they you
just like some of us just too healthy
right you know
you know they have potting soil in it
they'll have semen from uh slovenia
in it you're like what
you're just like damn man you got to
kind of should make you suck off
a bag of carrots after you have it you
know it's just some of it's just getting
too healthy
i missed the original smoothies that
thing was mostly sugar dude
and then they'd hit you with two scoops
of protein powder
and they have like the one dude in town
he was like oh
i work at gnc on paul kolkata
i'm eating meat right now in my head
he would record himself eating meat with
a video and then just
play it back while he was eating while
he was also eating meat later
you know he'd have at night he would
sleep next to an audio of him just
sounds of him eating meat his names guys
got bacon brain man
oh i got this bad smoothie damn
oh
oh my god
oh is is this a in it this
this thing has a real enema type feel to
it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you